hey I'm Noah I'm Lana and today we're
doing the wired auto-complete interview
[Music]
how to say no Santonio Noah Centennial
no noah centennial centennial centennial
centennial centennial centennial
noah Santonio how old Noah sent a nail
tool how to meet how to meet Noah sent
today Oh
a lot of ways you know if you're living
no problem you can meet me if you're
breathing air probably hi Ellie how tall
is Noah sent an arrow in feet whose feet
are we talking about are we talking
about Lana's feet are we talking about
my feet it's a different amount of okay
I'm not a feet you know I think we're
talking about the metric measurement Oh
like 12 inches I'm 6 feet 2 inches just
I'm 6 feet and one-sixth of a foot how
did Noah Santonio become an actor I
became an actor because my sister wanted
to audition for an agency that helped
you get another agency they were like a
starter agency and when she wanted to
audition I just wanted to go play soccer
and my parents said no we're not hiring
a babysitter you're gonna come with and
support your sister so that when I got
there they asked me if I was gonna
audition and I said no and then they
said no you'd be good at this and I was
like okay I'll try it and I tried it and
I loved it and I never stopped how to
get Noah synteny O'Hare
buzz it oh yeah you're a simple now oh
yeah I was like oh man you gotta like
shift the way you curl your hair cuz
it's kind of buzz your head super simple
what is Lana what is a lot of Condor
Lana Condor is a human being a human
girl love it not a bird what age is Lana
Condor I'm 22 years young 22 yeah that's
what is a lot of Condor
nope mm-hmm have a snapshot I do I'm
never honored but I do have it asking
what movies has a lot of Condor been
list them I'm not gonna really see her
unless I'm a total angel x-men excellent
choice tell the boys otherwise PS I
still love you always a forever oh it's
a similar Jean Patriots Day
I'm movie called summer night and a
movie called high school lover which I
shot here in the USA oh that's cool oh
you shot that gosh I think I was like 18
if you were 18 we were here at the same
time waiting working really maybe in the
same year fun fact we have pretty much
the same birthday you're 10 I'm 11
you're 9 I'm 11 that's right yeah but
when we would work together we would
always work on our birth on our
birthdays so we would celebrate our
birthdays together yeah yeah you got a
cake and I got a cup cupcakes love
cupcake cakes yeah that's great what
kind of dog does Lana Condor have Oh
her name is Amy and she is a you shut
your face let's let's not but her name
is Benji
I think the rescue said she's like a
hound mix terrier Emma gets carsick and
I gave him a me in the car in the car
tower and she was on it and she doesn't
tell me that I'm he gets carsick and
then she gives me the dog to hold when
inevitably if she goes up mm-hmm you
succeeded
yeah and I'm still anxious ain't a
lateral anxiety I know she was anxious -
she was cute though no I sent Denise oh
there is it no details though dog she's
dead she died like four years ago maybe
five or six maybe like this maybe
they're like there's no sense anyone
have a dog or maybe he's got like a dog
personality or we like Northington a oh
you want dog yeah I know something doc
dog like hey man who's that kid from
Saul okay right well there's no
incentive no dog yeah dog dog dog
no it's Antonio work out like what is
your work No
since nail workout yes nice does Noah
center now have tattoos I don't I am not
that - okay nice cars they like tattoos
but emotional mmm the scars in the
inside man on the outside Hasani what is
Noah sent Tania's full name Noah
Gregory sent the nail nails I can say it
man was very talented strengthened now
Gregory that's her destination with
those name with his name is Gregory what
was Noah sent tanios first movie the
first movie I ever did was a small
independent film made for negative money
in Miami and I was like I might have
been a cuz I just started to see this
and it was a musical Oh a Christian
funded film called Abraham and Sarah and
I played Ishmael and I was like did you
see I didn't sing thank God
maybe if I had sang then I would have
like continued to sing and maybe I'd say
you have a beautiful voice you do you do
oh I like singing but I don't think by
any means I've like yeah thank you I
think he does
where is Lana Condor from Vietnam where
is a lot of Condor right now in
Manhattan in New York
Lana Condor fun facts any fun facts
where's I like it's pretty exclusively
read thrillers like gone girl there yeah
yeah there's like a running joke in my
family that if the book has like in the
title has like murder dead or girls in
it I'll probably read it that's on a
condor as Jubilee all right give us your
best Jubilee impression oh my god yeah I
know one just just a look I don't know
here let go here Oh is Lana Condor
left-handed damn yeah left-handed all
right no why didn't you wear
you're left-handed maybe is no sense in
a Oh his NOAA Santa Barbara flow related
it's my father tell everybody where my
brother sometimes I mean we kinda look
alike but it's more so the way that we
talk and our mannerisms and like our
inflection points yeah yeah look way
more like earlier now I'm I just look
like the other herself no he does not
you look like a military man yes there
you go there is no ascent to nail a
taurus is no sense an AO left-handed no
I'm right-handed I'm kind of happy -
shoes is no ascent to nail Australian no
but my mom lived in Australia for the
beginning portion of her life she was
born in America and in Australia for
like 12 years and then she came back
good question the more you know there's
a lot of Condor have tattoos no no no I
don't have that okay there's a lot of
Condor have siblings I do I have a
brother his name is Arthur Artie kannada
aarti farty there's a lot of Commodore
Legno Center now yeah I dunno I mean it
depends on them on the day of course I
like it with ours we've been asked most
of those questions yeah there's one
that's not in there which i think is
weird cuz though it's like a lot of
condor feet and i'm like but why why do
you need to know about my foot feet
ain't no but I want anything to do with
my feet that's for sure